You have just seen how to write a program that determines the largest of a
number of input values, but that program had an annoying flaw. The user had to
type in all of the values and if there are a lot of them that can get really
tedious. What we really want to do is read the values from a file. To read a
value from a file, you can use the scanner class. But you construct the scanner
with an object of a file class. And in turn you need to construct that file
object by giving the name of the input file. Now, there's a bit of a catch
here, when we put this code inside the main method, we need to deal with the
possibility that there is no file called input.text. If that file was indeed
missing, then the file constructor would terminate with what's called a file
not found exception. That exception is considered so serious that we must tell
Java that we are aware of it. That's done by putting this class throws
FileNotFoundException behind main. We're not covering exception handling in
this course, so this is just another one of those things that I'm going to have
to ask you to just do. Once we're done with this, everything else is easy, now
the scanner works. Every bit as the scanner you've been using quite a bit. You
can simply call has next double, and then read a value by calling next double.
Well, have a go at it. Modify the program that computes the largest value, so
that it reads the values from a file.